مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في الساعات
الماضيه بالتدوينات تهاجم مغني الراب
الكنديه جريك بعد اتهامه باهانه المراه
المغربيه في احدث اغنيه له اصدرها في
الرابع من نوفمبر الجاري وتفاعل نشطاء
مغنيه دريك التي وصف من خلالها المراه
المغربيه باوصاف مشينه وطالب عدد من
المغاربه عبر منصات التواصل باتخاد
اجراءات قانونيه ضد مغني الراب الكنديه
[موسيقى]
رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقطع فيديو
لمعركه حاميه نشبت بين جمالين في احد
الاسواق ما استدعى تدخل عدد من الموجودين
لمحاوله انهاء الازمه وفي النهايه استطاع
الموجودون من التفرقه بينهما بصعوبه بسبب
احدهما عن الاخر باستخدام السياره لانهاء
المعركه
مين ده صفر صفر
[موسيقى]
يا ولد
حطه حطه
[موسيقى]
صور صادمه تداولها رواد مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي في مصر لطالبات يرتدين الاسدال
الايراني كزين مدرسيه موحد وتبين انها في
مدرستنا الاعداديه للبنات التابعه لمدينه
نبرو وكشفت المعلومات ان طالبات المدرسه
وبقرار من ادارتها يرتدين هذا الزي منذ
سنوات بالمخالفه لقرارات وزاره التربيه
والتعليم التي تفرض زيا اخر وعلق وكيل
وزاره التربيه والتعليم ناصر شعبان انه
ستتم احاله الواقعه للتحقيق ومحاسبه
المسؤولين عنها مشيرا الى انه سيتم تغييره
زي الطالبات والزامهن بارتداء الزي الذي
حددته وزاره التعليم
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء اليوم الى اللقاء